kommt auch erst junge junge
warum so die werden gleich noch beide
sterben die werden beide sterben
ich schwöre es euch die werden beide
sterben so das haben die sich so
verdient ich bin nur zu den
rübergeflogen und ich habe es kein mal
in der konfi gelesen dass ich nicht zu
den fliegen darf alter jetpack aufladen
jetzt gibt's krieg jetzt gibt's krieg
brocken vermutlich steckt mich unter
eine decke mit denen und jack alles in
die luft bei den leuten herzlich
willkommen zu einer weiteren folge vom
megapark diesmal wieder mit face cam am
start und zwar möchte ich heute mein
haus bauen
nein also beginnt es noch den server
drauf und zwar soll mein haus ein
riesenpenis werden der soll über der
stadt leuchten die sonst was eventuell
werde ich bald noch mal ein richtiges
haus bauen wenn ich mein grundstück
verweigern darf nach dahin wollte ich
eventuell fragen und mein haus wird
erstmal riesenpenis werden und zwar eine
riesige riesenpenis den stell dich da so
einfach hin und durch den penis durch
kann man auch dadurch das loch dann
einfach im keller gehen habe ich schnell
vorgedacht dafür braucht es aber eine
menge wolle
und ich habe nicht so viel wolle ich
schaue erst mal noch also ich hab im
livestream ich schon so ein bisschen mit
string so durch geguckt und sowas als ob
ich wolle habe ich habe allerdings nicht
so viel ich schaue einfach nochmal weil
ich habe ein paar drinks auf jeden fall
mit denen man sich auch so ein bisschen
wolle machen kann hätte ich auch häufig
zu finden seien so von monster monster
drops so egal also das was auf jeden
fall erstmal mit string string können
wir jetzt zu ja ok kommen 15 wurde geht
fit ich brauche so viel wolle wie es
geht deswegen werde ich wahrscheinlich
bei anderen ordner nachschauen und ich
habe jetzt hier erstmal im himmel hin
und zwar zwei drei vier fünf
ich kann ich nichts hinein
45 so da muss kein 10.45 bis falsch so
sei das ist so scheiße mit jetpack zu
bauen
warte ich jetzt mal ganz kurz abzubauen
so zog es doch gut so man jetzt
verbrauche ich mich hier die ganze zeit
von der firma her
so jetzt wollte ich hier so eine coole
reinbauen halte ich glaub ich schaffe
heute erst ein junge wie also jetzt vom
penis bauen her
junge wie wie scheiße ich brauche
einfach viel mehr wollte ich glaube ich
ich gönne mir einfach ein paar schafe
von skate oder irgendwie wer war das
noch mit dem chef nicht ob das was geht
und dann geht's ab jungs dann habe ich
auf jeden fall mehr wolle
also ich werde dann so fahren dass ich
da einmal durchlaufen müssen dann habe
ich unendlich weh so nach dem motto ich
brauche halt mehr strings aber strings
bekommt man halt nur durch monster töten
und ich habe nicht nur monster für mich
hat zwar mops bonner mit spinnen und ach
ja stimmt da könnte man theoretisch
endlich was draus bauen
übrigens sollte viele fragen sich immer
ja ich halte die folgen aber du hast
immer schon sachen die du in der letzten
folge nicht hat es ja weil ich immer
live streams mache die kündige ich aber
meistens nur bei facebook an
ich werde die bald machen wenn ich die
partner bin werde ich das auch dann
immer so bei youtube ankündigen damit
zurzeit ist mir das einfach so ich
möchte mein kanal so nicht damit zu spam
sind nach dem motto alter das hat sich
argentinien gewitter versteht was ich
meine also ich will nicht dass das auf
einmal sein video ist so livestream so
da habe ich ihn nicht so bock drauf
es kommt obendrauf
ja meine wolle reicht auf kleinsten aus
alter ich habe nur das kein kleines
wissel hier
ich dachte eigentlich hätte mehr
ich schaue einfach mal bei anderen und
schreibe ich den dass ich mir ein
bisschen voller genommen habe ich wollte
diesen penis es mit meiner stadt setzen
aber das ist mir aufgefallen dass wenn
die sagen dass der krake ist können kann
ihn jeder abbauen
deswegen setze ich das einfach auf meine
tochter kann so können die zusagen dass
das kkw die kunst nicht abbauen
die müssen stehen lassen ich hab gedacht
dass ich mir einfach ein sonnen sondern
riesiges leuchtfeuer nicht leuchtfeuer
sondern aus los dann sowas riesiges
bauer aber das habe ich einfach nicht
jetzt kommt er trotzdem darauf dieser
penner
jetzt kommt der trotzdem dort jetzt
kommen dies trotzdem jetzt kommen die
trotzdem h
die garde gefragt ob die dabei sein
wollen wenn ich das kann ich mir wolle
ausleihen
ich werde die komplette innenstadt den
stadtkern geflogen ich könnte schwören
ich glaube eben zu den rüber
nein er sein maul halten eltern haben
die das eigentlich schon gesehen hier
hinten
auch wieder hat die schnauze und gehe
nicht auf unser grundstück vor
produziere du weißt warte die folge
kommt auch erst sondern junge junge
warum er soll seine schnauze halten
alter warum gilt der mich dieser [ __ ]
ich wollte gerade schreiben dass die
voll ich jetzt mal ein bisschen erst in
zwei wochen kommt ich bin auch
produzieren ich gehe jetzt mal ein
bisschen junge das ist scheiße
so jetzt will ich meine sachen zurück
ihr verdammten horn box dann bring mir
meine sachen
da wird bestimmt noch einer
drüberfliegen gib her junge wenn ihr
jetzt die sache nicht jedem alter ich
komme tnt an junge wenn die mir die
sache nicht geben
gib her oder ich komme die folge hat auf
einmal themen sinne sinneswandel hinter
sich
die folge mit mittlerweile ganz anderen
sinn
gib mir die sachen alter ich meine es
ernst
schaue extra weg nur auf gomez es liegt
an mir vorbei dieser penner wenn da
irgendwas nicht beiseite wenn da
irgendwas nicht bei ist
wenn da irgendwas er geil bist du jetzt
die tot
okay was mache ich denn
gib mir jetzt sofort die sachen oder ich
sprenger grundstück sofort
dann hol die junge ich wünsche mir dass
die mir die sache nicht geben ich
wünsche mir richtig dass die sachen
nicht geben weil dann mache ich ein
portal zum mond zu deren grundstück und
es ist alles im eimer von denen das will
ich den sogen
was für ja moment komme ich meine das
ernst vorteil mond portalhaus ach ja das
stimmt hier die hätten den livestream
gefunden sondern kiste glaube ich gibt
heute nach einem pieks und sonders den
scheiß gibt mir halt den ganzen scheiß
aber nicht meine richtigen sachen und
gib mir den solar helm junge ich schwöre
junge die sollen sich verpissen alter so
die werden gleich noch beide sterben die
werden beide sterben
ich schwöre es euch die werden beide
sterben so das haben die sich so
verdient ich bin nur zu den
rübergeflogen und ich habe es einmal in
der konfi gelesen dass dich nicht zu den
fliegen darf alter aussehen diese konfis
unnötig 2000 minuten 1000 minuten das
kommt 1000 nachrichten pro minute wollte
sein so jetpack aufladen jetzt gibt's
krieg jetzt gibt es krieg brocken 40
steckt mich unter eine decke mit denen
und jack alles in die luft bei denen es
ist wahr die habe ich einfach nur
getötet und meine level sind weg meine
level
ich glaube das war nicht mehr alles was
dir was nicht von denen hatte er was die
von mir haben
eine diaschau
so
bonn
wolle kommen so diamond just play
electric kressl
ich weiß jetzt damit anfangen soll mit
dieser mit dieser komischen bottle da so
junge ok
wenn ich den noch einmal sehen wenn er
mir einmal was until alter durchlass den
jetzt ganz einfach ein lava plumpsen
ganz easy oder auf die platte bei mojang
new york schuldig auch noch rache alter
hat mich einfach so umgebracht da drin
hatte ich nur eisenachs bogen das hat
etwas hatte ich dennoch das haar ist
oder eine karotten alter die kriegen das
so zurück die kriegen ich will eine
rache machen wo die sich aufregen aber
überhaupt noch drauf ja die sind noch
drauf ich bin der rache wo die sich
aufregen aber wohl nicht so viel von dem
kaputt geht am besten sonne vor
produktion von denen einfach mal zeigen
ich würde gern sehen wie die in den
pimmel da reihen laufen
wenn dann die explosion hören
oder ich stelle mich einfach mit dem
rücken an das grundstück von denen und
produziert er produziert provoziert die
einfach was ist das jetzt eigentlich in
kisten
was sind das für kisten diese schwarzen
vw müssen dass das grundstück noch von
selbst
das habe ich echt noch nicht gesehen das
ist einfach nur seine fläche naja also
wie kann ich mich am brocken verbrechen
schreibt mal bitte in die kommentare
rein dann werde ich da so ein bisschen
darauf hören und eventuell sogar machen
ja ich überlege gerade was kann ich denn
da machen ich habe allgemein auf viel zu
wenig wolle dass ich jetzt gerade etwas
produktives hier machen kann
deswegen ich überlege gerade was was
kann ich denn machen um die zu ärgern
was könnte ich denn machen
ich könnte einen witherspoon ich könnte
einfach auf dem grundstück von denen
witherspoon alter dass er echt heftig
aber ich weiß nicht wenn ich einen
witherspoon ob denn doch zu denen dahin
komplette ich glaub ich kann das ja mal
probieren vielleicht das mal machen
oder was kann man denn noch machen ich
nehme sicherheitshalber schon mal ihren
zauberstab mit
ich konnte auch vize premier unter das
haus über das ausland platzieren aber
die rache gab schon das kann ich ja noch
mal
was habe ich denn alles ich überlege
gerade echt wie könnte ich mich an denen
rechnen
wie könnte ich mich rächen ohne viel
kaputt zu machen aber die irgendwie zu
töten so dass es legal ist dass ich kann
die nicht legal töten
ich kann ich kann ihn nicht legal töten
weil die auf ihrem grundstück sind
das kann ich echt nicht aber die meinen
auch die wollen nicht mehr aufnehmen
weil die gerade hatte nehmt ihr auf weil
die eigentlich zu viel produziert haben
deswegen wollten die ich mitmachen dann
geht runter [ __ ] tha police regelverstoß
die sollen runter vom server gehen
oder log die einfach so zu meinem
grundstück ich log sie einfach zu meinem
grundstück und ankündigte hier der babys
ein ball nicht aufgenommen hat fußt da
haben aber andere ohne beine um die
häuser ziehen
da haben aber andere aufgenommen wie ich
darum gelaufen bin bei euch könntet ihr
jetzt alles mögliche machen ohne dass es
einer reportet aufzeichnete report
recorded wollte schrempp und wo fliegt
malte hin wenn malta aus der stadt
fliegt dann fliegt ihm hinterher und
kindern
vom schrecken als ob ich damit ja ja
komm flieg noch ein bisschen weiter ein
fakt der kommt wieder zurück
calibre das wird ein krieg über der
stadt alter
die tore schießt nimmt ab dieser [ __ ]
heute sind meine sind das noch meine
warte ja das sind meine ich könnte
einfach mal fies sein und ganz von ganz
oben auf das grundstück von den
fallenden mit einem portal zurück zu mir
oder was könnt ihr noch machen mit dem
portal
ich könnte
nein das lvs wenn ich ein lava blocken
mitnehmen und dann werden darüber setzte
das werden das wäre nicht cool
was kann ich denn noch machen könnte
echt ein portal zum mond setzen
das portal ist da dran
doch ist es
haben sie jetzt da unten im portal ich
weiß es nicht müssen die eigentlich ja
eigentlich schon glaube ich war ganz
grob vermutet aber sonst alter das recht
mich echt auf alter ich möchte mich am
liebsten bei den direkt rächen für das
was die mir hier ne
und so das regt mich echt auf alte das
ist eine folge in der ich einfach nur
rache plane und keine ahnung habe wie
ich die umsetzen soll
ich könnte auch einfach alte ich habe
eine idee ich habe eine idee ich hab'
ich habe eine richtig geile idee ob das
umsetzbar ist weiß ich nicht ich habe
auf jeden fall ne geile idee
ich werde mir ja egal das kann ich ja
sogar jetzt machen ich gehe zu simon der
seine eier und sport einfach richtig
viele hühner bei den auf dem grundstück
die sind doch wann die nicht hier hatten
der noch mal seine bücher hörbücher
die waren doch hier herunter opel soll
ich mal rotwild wird nimmt man spaß dass
damit macht man nicht gerne späße soll
ich jetzt hier hoch ganz hoch ich ja die
waren ganz oben so den wir zum paria
schon hier mit züchter bei mir so ein
paar hühner
wir sind das jetzt auch ein pass tax und
die bringe ich alle zu brocken vor sich
weiß zwar noch nicht wie
aber dass wir definitiv in der ache
werden so ungleich gehe ich erstmal vom
server runter damit die denken ich bin
nicht da dann denke ich dass ich das
wenn ich das im livestream weitermachen
ich weiß es nicht
die wahrscheinlich nicht bereit schon
wahrscheinlich dann in der nächsten
folge wenn ich mich noch erholen werden
dann hier noch alles nur farben ich
laufe einfach so ein bisschen rum
ich kann immer ich glaub's kate ist ein
hatten farm glaube ich
ich schau mal ich weiß nicht ob der
hühner hat als ich nehme nur die eier
mit von daher ist es ja egal ich glaube
ja nichts der hat nur schweine der sonst
noch was
auch keine scheine heraus
ich bin hat mich hinein gekommen
hey ich muss doch irgendwer irgendwie
bei wetten dass irgendwer muss doch hier
noch links haben oder china
in das gesehen diese penner alter deal
auf jetzt einfach nur rum und
kontrollieren dass ich nicht zu denen
aus grundstücke die sind so frech alter
die sind so frisch
es ist nicht mehr normal ich werde
einfach in den nächsten in der nächsten
zeit wie eine hühnerfarm machen das
mache ich jetzt noch eben so hab ich
dann meine freunde hingelegt hat und an
welche ganzen hühner zu denen aufs
grundstück packen und wenn es letzte ist
was ich tue ich weiß auch gar nicht wie
soll ich die denn alle dahin kann mache
ich einfach so einen riesigen weg über
die stadt drüber oder in unterirdischen
gründlich bauen
das könnte ich theoretisch sogar jetzt
mache mich einfach unterirdisch dahin
graben
nein nein mann ich hab so viele
rachepläne meinem kopf das gar nicht hin
so also ich würde erstmal die wiener
komme ich mal jetzt mal die hier
ich muss mich irgendwie bei den rechten
auch halter da kann man richtig viel
raus auf jeden fall muss ich mich
wirklich irgendwie an den rechen ihr
könnt mir jetzt ist eure aufgabe
schreibt mir in die kommentare
wie ich mich am brocken thums rechnen
kann dafür dass die mich getötet haben
uns was anderes und es soll episch
werden
das soll keine normale rache mit
irgendwem tnt werden dass wir irgendwas
episches werden
am besten gehen auf ihr grundstück
treten auf eine tnt platte und dann ist
so eine riesige kettenreaktion irgendwie
sowas keine ahnung auf jeden fall was
episches echter kann schon passen wie
sich der samen drin so ich nehme es
erstmal die kinder die hier drin sind
damit raus so kommt mit alle
nacheinander so mitkommen mitkommen
mitkommen mit komm mit kommen mit kommt
schon wieder reinkommen
frauen blog einer legt erstmal vor mir
ich brauche am besten noch ein blog
kommt mit meiner kleinen gefiederten
freunde ja ja eher eine reine 1 los
hallo hallo
az die wieder geil auf mich so kommt ihr
über ja ja fein machst du das nur 1
nummer 2 nummer drei und nummer vier zu
blöd auf dieses ding zu gehen ok effekt
noch mal vier auch ein mit ihr so dass
nun die hühner fahren und diese farm
wird bald komplett of broken kramp
grundstück sein
da wird alles so voll sein mit hühner
dass die nicht mehr klarkommen werden
das wird so heftig ich hoffe einfach ich
habe noch leute dabei die da mitmachen
ich gucke jetzt einfach mal noch mal bei
anderen ob die irgendwie eier haben oder
irgendwie sowas warte vielleicht
allerdings die welche das sind ein paar
eier da wird er es wohl kaum in den
hermann machen ich meine hühner könnte
mir scheiß egal sein er hat so viel
vitamin ist das
denn notfallärzte blöcke kinder
nein ich suche ja nicht solche sachen
nicht so her
ich brauche ja wir brauchen euro hat er
denn sein lager dingsbums ich verstehe
das echt nicht wieder der hat noch nicht
sortiert einfach irgendwie ne
apropos ich kann eigentlich wieder eben
zum monster falle gehen
so warte noch einen runter so wie ich
hier nochmal runter gegangen
so here lang und jetzt ein wenig
so viel ist ja gar nicht
es war okay
danke ich mir wieder also brockens wird
richtig kassieren und das ganze
allerdings bekommen die ganzen hühner
auf ihr grundstück wenn ihr noch
irgendwas wisst wie ich mich an den
rechen kann dann schreibt auf jeden fall
einfach in die kommentare ich liebe die
diesmal alle durch und die könnt ihr
einfach mal daumen hoch gehen wenn ihr
wollt dass ich mich heftig rechte oder
einfach richtig viele sandwiches
wo sind denn die herr wo sind die
haben die ja ich weiß nich haben die das
schon gesehen ich wette die haben das
tnt schon gesehen unter der druckplatte
von funden von links von dem tunnel
naja egal freunde ich will das mal sagen
schreibt wenn wir das um die kommentare
dass wir jetzt keine produktive folge es
einfach nur rache folge ich nenne die
einfach brocken zusammen ihr werdet
sterben oder irgendwie sowas und
schreibt mir das wirklich einfach in die
kommentare ich beantworte das und ich
würde mich über einen daumen hoch freuen
und wir sind dann beim nächsten mal
wieder und ich hab euch alle ganz lieb
und warum mache ich das ich krieg das
emi hin so zuschneiden dass es nachher
funktioniert